thomas bonjour alors nouvelles
mobilisations sociales ce samedi les
premières pour jean castex absolument
manifestation des gilet jaune qui se
déroule depuis maintenant un peu plus
d'une heure et demie dans les rues de la
capitale on est parti à proximité du
bataclan en direction de la place
d'italie on est actuellement en
direction de la place de la nation une
des étapes de cette manifestation
manifestation qui n'a réuni que quelques
dizaines de gilet jaune ils sont environ
50 à avoir répondu à cet appel il ya
beaucoup plus de forces de l'ordre que
de manifestants c'est un comble pour
cette journée de mobilisation une faible
participation à cette manifestation qui
s'explique notamment par le fait qu'il y
à 3 me trois manifestations de gilet
jaune qui ont été déclarés ou autorisés
aujourd'hui dans la capitale ce qui
explique l'écart piment en quelque sorte
des manifestants interrogés certains des
participants sur justement cette faible
mobilisation je propose d'écouter à ce
sujet à ausy lellouche était tout à
l'heure dans le cortège des gilet jaune
il est normal que ce soit faible
mobilisation vu la répression qu'il ya
eu des tas ils sont servis des bras
armés on va dire des policiers et
beaucoup de gens ont été et de la
justice parce que beaucoup de gens ont
été condamnés
beaucoup de gens étaient aussi blessé et
il est normal que les gens aient peur de
sortir
ça c'est une chose et en même temps il
ya le quotidien je pense que on a fait
ce qui n'est jamais arrivé c'est à dire
un mouvement qui a duré maintenant on
peut dire deux ans mais vraiment actif
pendant un an et demi et je pense qu'on
a tous besoin de vivre on a tous des
obligations et il est normal qu'à un
moment donné on est obligé de revenir à
nos obligations parce que sinon on va se
retrouver nous-mêmes a dénoncé les gens
qui sont sdf les gens dans la précarité
les inégalités on va se retrouver dehors
quoi vous l'aurez compris libé pour les
jeux les jaunes c'est de continuer à
occuper le terrain continuer à faire
entendre leurs revendications faire
comprendre au gouvernement qu'ils ne
céderont
un mais dans les rangs des manifestants
que nous avons croisé aujourd'hui
certains estiment qu'il faudrait
peut-être revoir le champ d'action peut
être ne plus manifester tous les samedis
comme c'était le cas avant la période de
confinement en tout cas cette
manifestation se déroule au lendemain de
la nomination d'un nouveau premier
ministre jean castex on a interrogé les
participants à cette manifestation sur
ce qu'il pensait de cette nomination je
propose de les écouter au micro de
nicolas brun clair je pense que c'est
juste un changement un changement de
marionnettes en fait été et que ça
changera pas grand chose est sûre ils
resteront toujours sur leur politique et
on obtiendra toujours pas ce qu'on
voudra c'est un quart une plaisanterie
moi je pense pas que ça va changer grand
chose étant donné qu'il est choisi par
le pouvoir en place
le gouvernement il est uni d'un seul
bloc contre sa population j'hésite pas
le dire finalement la démocratie
aujourd'hui qu'on veut nous vendre c'est
un simulacre
voilà voilà donc pour les revendications
et les positionnements de ces
manifestants quant au nouveau premier
ministre la manifestation qui se
poursuit qui s'achèvera tout à l'heure
sur la place d'italie dans une ambiance
évidemment vous l'imaginez plutôt
paisible et bon enfant puisqu'il n'ya
donc je vous rappelle que quelques
dizaines de manifestants qui ont fait le
déplacement pour cette manifestation
hebdomadaire d'un gilet jaune
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas abonnés en direct de
l'un des trois cortèges des gilets
jaunes cet après-midi dans les rues de
paris